الاوروبية وفزت بكل شيء وانا
الان امام تحد جديد في اسيا. بعد
المحلية برسم ميسي علي مستغلا
زخم الفوز بكأس العالم. بعد ضربة
برأيكم? الاحداث والتطورات. شهدت
العاصمة العراقية تظاهرات مدنية
على مقربة من البنك المركزي
للتمديد بخفض الدينار امام
بان كوريا الجنوبية لا تمتلك
النووية. فهل يرفع هذا التصريح
الاستطلاع الامريكية لمعرفة مصدر
ضربات فمن اين سيكون مصدرها
التصريحات المتضاربة في وسائل
الاعلام الغربي حول الحليفين
قادة الدول الغربية بتعزيز دفاع
بلاده. مشيرا الى ان روسيا تخطط
وزير الخارجية التركي مولود
جاويش اوغلو يقول انه مع نظيره
هذا العثماني ينتقل من سياسة
الحرب الى سياسة السلام. ها هو
وقذائفنا سنكتب رسائلا لاعدائنا
ولا مكان للضعفاء. هنا تتناثر
الصينيون يدركونه بالسياسة فها
هي بكين تندد بالقيود التي
الاقتصادي الذي لا يسر عدوا ولا
صديق فقد اصبح الشعب البريطاني
الروسي. لينضم رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشيسوناك الى
تحذير لموسكو كجزء من تعهد
الرئيس جو بايدن بالدفاع عن كل
التوالي لسفن الدول الثلاث تحت
اسم الدخان. لكن ما كل ما يريده
موقف يونسوكا المحرج? فلقد كشف
كيم هشاشة تحالفهم يا سادة.
تحركات السلام لا تتوقف لاردوغان
ليعتزم الرئيس التركي مواصلة
الجهود لاستئناف عام التفاوض في
العام الجاري بين روسيا
بتسعة اضعاف وتطلق جوا وبحرا
وبرا. ويمكنها حمل رؤوس نووية.
دير الزور السورية تعرضت للهجوم
بخمسة صواريخ لتحلق طائرات
تقييم امكانية لقاء الرئيسين
التركي والسوري. لكن المتحدث
اردوجان والاسد على جدول الاعمال
وسيكون خلال الفترة المقبلة.
العجلة التركية تدور. عجلة السلم
تدور بسرعة والنتائج تاتي تباعا.
الدولار. كريستيانو رونالدو.
سعيد باختيار نادي النصر ولدي
السوري في النصف الثاني من الشهر
الجاري. مضيفا انه سيتم لاحقا
الطرفين وفق وكالة نوفوستي. لكن
هنا يأتي الخبر الذي قد يغير
مبدأ المعاملة بالمثل. كيم يربك
حسابات الخصوم. بادخنة صواريخنا
واوكرانيا للتوصل الى وقف اطلاق
نار نظرا لكونه على تواصل مع
عجلة السلام التركية. القاعدة
العسكرية الامريكية والتي تقع في
وستبحر الى هدفها المحدد. حيث
تمتلك هذه الفرقاطة قدرات خارقة
الادميرالجورشكوف. والتي مباشرة
نحو ساحة الحرب الاوكرانية
بايدن احرج نظيره الكوري الجنوبي
حينها ورفض مقترحه ليأتي اليوم
تفتقر الى اساس علمي واكدت انها
قد ترد باجراءات حازمة مبنية على
العديد من دول العالم على
القادمين من الصين بسبب الموجة
الجديدة لجائحة كورونا وقالت
انها تنطوي على اجراءات تمييزية
باسم حزب التنمية والعدالة
الحاكم عمر جليك يقول ان لقاء
التوضيح من البيت الابيض ان
المناورات المشتركة ليست مطروحة
بايدن ويوكسل بشأن التهديدات
المتنامية من كوريا الشمالية لكن
للطائرات التي حصلت عليها كييف
بمساعدة واشنطن تنقذ الارواح
تدهور قيمتها الشرائية فنان
ارجنتيني يزيد من قيمة العملة
كييف القوية موسكو ترد الصفعة
للاوكران في جوانب مختلفة. فهل
الكثير لاقدمه للنصر وللكرة
السعودية. لعبت في اهم الاندية
رومانيا لتقول واشنطن ان نشر هذه
القوة في رومانيا يعد بمثابة
هكذا هي القواعد الصينية لسياسة
البلاد لتعلن بكين انها تجري مع
وبالذكاء تناور الجيران
وباستغلال الفرص تجمع الحلفاء.
هذا العام حسب وكالة تاس الروسية
وهي المناورة الثانية على
جنوب افريقيا وروسيا مناورات
بحرية مشتركة لمدة عشرة ايام في
المحيط الهندي قبالة الساحل
الجنوبي لافريقيا في فبراير من
ام ان هذه العملية هي مجرد قنبلة
اعلامية الهدف منها مراوغة
هناك خطرا محدقا لمواجهة امريكية
وربما مواجهة عالمية. ومن يدري
روسيا? الصين تستعد عسكريا.
بالقوة تراوغ الامريكان.
ففرقة النسور الامريكية الصاخبة
مائة وواحد لاول مرة وعلى بعد
شبر من اراض حلف الناتو اذا فهل
يتجاهل الامريكان تحذيرات روسيا
امتار من ساحة الحرب تجري
تدريبات ومناورات عسكرية في
غلاء المعيشة. الخطر هنا لا
يقتصر على اوكرانيا فقط بل ان
القوة الحقيقية. وصواريخ مجهولة
تتساقط على قاعدة امريكية في
انخفاض عملته. رد روسيا المخيف.
قوانين الحروب هي الاقرب
حسب ما نشرت البي بي سي يتناول
وجبتين في اليوم فقط وذلك بسبب
المجنحة. مضيفا ان الروس يراهنون
على ارهاق الشعب الاوكراني
سوناك بدعم طويل الامد لكييب.
اهلا يا سوناك ماذا عن وضع بلادك
لحرب شاملة وطويلة الامد على
بلاده بالطائرات مسيرة والصواريخ
المؤيدين لخطوات زلينسكي. وخلال
اتصال هاتفي مع الرئيس تعهد
تغيير دفة الحرب وتأخير هزيمتها.
متعهدا بالعمل على افشال المخطط
بقدر قائد جيشه. وتخوفا من ردة
فعل روسيا طالب زينيستي عددا من
للسيطرة الاوكرانية الكاملة. لكن
فولوديمير زينينسكي ليس مطمئنا
واستنفاذ طاقته. ليضيف ان روسيا
ستحشد كل امكانياتها من اجل
الاوكرانية. مضيفا ان الوضع في
الحدود مع بيلاروسيا يخضع
ديمترو كوليبا بدء نقل انظمة
باتريوت الامريكي الى اوكرانيا.
ليخرج قائد الجيش الاوكراني
مصرحا ان الصواريخ المضادة
لم تأت بمفردها ولكن بالتزامن مع
اعلان وزير الخارجية الاوكراني
اقتربت نهاية الحرب ليحين دور
المسلسلات والافلام تحركات روسيا
تشكل تحالفا جديدا وتحذر الغرب
هذا الاجراء. وكوريا الشمالية
السينما لمكافحة النازية الجديدة
وفق تعبيره. لامرك يا بوتين. هل
فيلما جميلا. هكذا قالها بوتين.
فهل حانت النهاية? رد روسي مزلزل
عاد بوتين ليطلب من سلطاته تصوير
فيلم سينمائي وثائقي وعرضه بدور
الادوار المتعددة حدث مهم. واضاف
ان الاسلحة القوية التي تحملها
جروشكوف تحمي روسيا من التهديدات
الخارجية على حد تصريحه. بينما
مكافحة ليؤكد بوتين ان بدء عمل
الفرقاطة التي لا مثيل لها وذات
ويا لها من قدرات خارقة
للتسيركون والتي يمكنها ايضا
على استخدام صواريخ الفرد صوتية.
والتي تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت
انهم بالمئات. لتتحرك موسكو
معلنة عن اطلاق فرقاتها المسماة
الاوكراني على قوات الروس في
ماكينبا اعلنت موسكو ارتفاع
للقوانين الفيزيائية اي لكل فعل
ردة فعل. وما دامت الحرب على ارض
الواقع فلابد لكل هجوم من ردة
فعل معاكسة. وبعد الهجوم
سوريا بينما يرفع ميسي عملة
بلاده يتظاهر العراقيون بسبب
حصيلة قتلى جيشها الى تسعة
وثمانين قتيلا. بينما تقول كيييف
تربك امريكا وحلفائها واردوغان
يلملم شتات الحروب وينطلق نحو
على الهجوم الاوكراني وزلنسكي
يصرخ ويستغيث والولايات المتحدة
مشهد واحد الحرب الروسية
الاوكرانية اكشن. جهزوا لهم
ينتهي الامر عند ذلك?
تتحرك والدعم يصل للاوكرانيين
وكييد لقد انقذتم الارواح. الصين